німецька істота в край трохи виводу
поєдинку своїх політики у тієї самі можна
влада знає що в роті алішер а завтра
з цієї дозвілля денної історії щоб на
завжди в витратах це крісло в Україні
сформувалася політична культура
як і чит-коду потрібно кажуть експерти
так ситуацію коли депутат бундестагу
статут на кримінальну ст-шку абу
стріляв у яншо храму діани на он і на
адже я б ти не можеш лов у курок
толку тут йдуть за значить нам менше
порушення
подавши депутат до соціальної проточної
партії бізнесу чорні або моє посвята
прозаїчніше школи ще на магія або диплом
юриста
хоч би на звідси писала у своїй брати
ще знайти росії і просто не знав з
черги рядка після type вона вже була
депутатську
і скандалу написала б просто врятував 1 травня
харчування за словом а експерт каяк що у
самого кулі канави старша волі
кудись uuid ставку
юму ланцюг відмовить кулері по партії
наприклад канцлер до ангелів арка яко
сама вишивала на посаду президента
Крістіана Вульфа попросила його потім вигляд
povestea на плутанину стиль стовбури до
уколу вульфу спалахнув корупційний
скандал samba і встав великим в історії
не машини президента мить і афіни вся на
лаві підсобних і дарма що й пішов вигляд
ставку
через підору хабарі суд ви правда вульфа
і давився таємною війною, однак авторитет
блоки диванів таті логічніше закутування
ура спав скандалу святилище 54 адже
сотки ним ти поважав ще wolf не видно і
своєї посади теж президент до слуху вся
задум
громадян з розслідування кінця по тому
рахунок обліку люди на це ще не давала та
там прощання почалося в желлі
політичної діяльності дільничного
струйного на і самий через його на них так
і так там ще фактурна настя
вахид гру стивен навіть важливими для
політика для його колег з партії випивши
пливу ними, приймаючи журналістка, спили
нота на ґрунтів на розслідування
зважує куріоа x usb листя так і
правах шкоди
більше журналістам піци ви порожній
нами 100 м прокурора у 2015 роті
міністр юстиції
та камаз вид права на пенсію федерального
генпрокурора
гарольда рангу через диск на журналістів
російська дочка і portal in its політик арк
у прилюдно ви секретні матеріали про
тещу федеральне відомство за корони
конституції хоче розширити st дружина
засув з моржами проти них порушилася
праву протримавши нас роду ціль ще несу
провалювала жорстко криті can адресу
право курантил
влади давав осі капітул вати in
прокурор витрати на саду а його
ініціативи не дали ходу